[Music]
as a ramble podcast have a good time
Tony trim yep and special guest Chicago
legend shark EULA what's up man what's
up man yourself
maintain and drinking some good beer and
just happy to be around in the room of
greatness
yeah I saw yesterday you say you got
bitten by a spider
yeah reclusive a reclusive yeah that's
the name that's the type of spider way
yeah that's what he said but the brown
recluse right yeah it hurts like yeah I
heard about that
where were you it was just this happened
like actually 90 days ago by didn't even
know cuz I'm a workhorse yeah I mean I
work a holic I mean yeah same thing but
you know you know when you're in pain
are you under weather you know how it is
being on the road a lot you're like I'm
gonna do this you don't realize how
serious some could be right I mean not
like life-threatening but he got bigger
like an incredible hulks pants yeah I
mean like his skins like it's like scary
because my legs are everything I you you
know legs are important for yeah and
weight around you get around town a lot
yeah so then I thought it was cuz of my
backpack I always have a lot of stuff in
it and then I was like trying to think
is it stress is it circulation yeah and
know that I went to the hospital for two
days they say you're fine everything's
fine
no no weird diseases no diabetes no
sexual transmitted diseases praise the
Lord we're like yeah it was just the
phrase that spider just praise God it's
just
hallelujah Arnett my my god born in the
hospital right after this really yeah
really it's that bad well it's they want
me to come in for a second checkup
Thursday for the check-in us whoa yes
whoa it's big
oh I see it man and then it went to my
ankle and it started like it looks like
I got a meatball and I didn't think that
I thought that was all urban myth I
didn't think that really happened
oh the problem is you get bit by it
[ __ ] you all up yeah like how long has
this been going on well I saw symptoms a
little like the scab I didn't know what
bit I thought was just maybe maybe a
mosquito I was like it give me a
mosquito in the wintertime I knew it was
something that bit me I know ain't no
rat cuz we got a transform that yeah but
it was a spider and we don't have bed
I've definitely don't have bedbugs she
got in my bag got a bunch of bedbug
bites
I said you bout to get a bedbug and your
cousin tonight you know that there's got
the bed bug bites going through this
right and I'm drinking on a sprite with
the bedbug bites it is tight bed bug
bites into the night and I bite her own
the booty yes she said she wanna fight I
said I fight in the bed bug bites never
get into the night and get it good is
that spiders spiders don't even probably
realize that they're that strong yeah
they just bitin oh it's just a bike for
them but they know I don't think spiders
bite a human being with it and think oh
this [ __ ] pump drawing this
person they're just kind of they don't
know what they're trying to eat you're
just trying to eat and then killing
people sometimes or maybe it was a
self-defense like you rolled over on the
spider and it was like [ __ ] you right
but he was still I don't think I think
they're just doing their bite I don't
think they realized the magnitude of
what they're doing
yeah yeah yeah and it's a few of them to
was like want to and then it's it was
scary because I thought it could have
been like somewhat I show someone this
is you got diabetes like hell no that
don't run in my family
like my mother died of breast cancer
2012 so I'd make extra conscious about
stuff you know how I carry myself and
after seeing her before she had breast
cancer five years before she had a two
knees replace from arthritis so like
man you know what
that's the only thing is just that damn
spider just you know just went went to
town on my damn leg yeah if you can say
something to that spider right now in
this podcast what'd you say [ __ ] you
[Laughter]
Tyler
sorry you got so did you develop some
kind of an arachnophobia now are you
scared of spiders now no I'm just gonna
like really I used to want him to lie to
kill insects yeah but now I'm just gonna
kill him cuz I don't want that to happen
you know daddy longlegs every type of
just spiders management they could take
over a world you know that they could
yeah
they can't organize like that and they
really don't like each other
all spiders I don't think so I don't you
know I'm just kind of talking out of my
ass now spiders I don't think spiders
they're very they seem very
individualistic you have their web and
if you come in through my web you're
gonna get caught in our each dog isn't
that like a web is not for kicking it
you never
yeah you have your spider you have your
life in spider and then you got your
little baby spiders and all the other
spiders can [ __ ] off yeah I think
spiders spiders are pretty solo they're
not like insects I think they just fight
her man I don't need friends I got eight
legs and I got this big-ass trap yeah
right
a web you get Carla advice favorite
Chicago jingle soprano department store
or a store commercial jingle you know
feel the warmth in luxury [ __ ] oldies
we get super local right now what else
that the zippers have a jingle
Severus the Sybaris is like we go down
being a hot seven [ __ ] looking for a
romantic getaway just for two
the search is over welcome to Savera
spool Suites where the possibilities for
romance are endless a virtual cocoon of
privacy Sybaris allows you to enjoy your
very own pool and waterfall retire to
the luxurious bedroom suite where
romance will certainly be sparked by the
glow of a fire and the unique amenities
of a severus getaway roses can delight
you and your loved one together secluded
in a world of privacy and extravagance
enjoying the intimacy of a soothing
whirlpool tub massage chair and
king-sized bed inspire your love life
for a few days or even a few hours with
5 convenient locations in the Midwest
Sybaris offers the opportunity to
celebrate your love in a unique way
escape the grind of daily life and enter
a world of relaxation where you can
indulge one another
ignite your romance get away from it all
welcome to Savera s--
but the Sybaris I would always see the
commercials for the Sivir is sweet yeah
you go to the zipper is sweet yeah and I
was a kid now like man I wanna go yeah
Marissa sound like baby kicking it up no
right it's funny what am I one of my
friends in high school through a through
a molly party and it's a race really for
the people I don't know Sibert what is
Sybaris is it's like a way like a
big-ass hotel room right we're like a
pool in a water slide in oh I got sex
dungeon basically suite so he's a good
name Sybaris I'm sure there's a lot of
booties that go around it yeah I mean
I'm sure there's a lot of fluids and all
kinds of stuff all in any hotel room no
but every hotel room you haven't every
hotel room has had some demonic [ __ ]
Molly party it was fun I'm Molly party
everybody was on Molly and just I wasn't
on the Molly or partaking I was just
there to just with some people Oh Molly
and and talk about it on his podcast
years later
so how many party like maybe like 15 of
us 15 yeah 14 on Molly yeah except for
one Tony all right it's a lot of Kate I
didn't know the friend that was I think
cuz the back then I was a smoking a lot
of weeds I think we just highlight no
Molly mouth [ __ ] rubbing like this
vapor rub on each other
no [ __ ] we're just derringers off
buzz people in the underwear jumping in
it was just you know it wasn't like an
orgy anything a bunch of kids
you know doing that yeah there was soup
she had just taken Molly for the first
time yes she told she's like okay we
take a picture I'll let you don't want
to take a business right now I don't
trust me you don't want to take a
picture what the [ __ ] your mouth is
doing right now
yeah sharp you you see people on drugs
all the time you see anybody yeah you
see everybody in all types of different
mental states oh man
it's crazy what I see yeah I've seen
people getting the head outside yeah
like I'll never forget to be on the
train I looked out the window you was
like I saw somebody getting a bj in a
platform yeah yeah people shoes anything
yeah no I just don't want them to see me
there by what I heard be later
not later but I don't say I just laugh I
kind of knock on the window like but
then I'm like oh what if I see this guy
again and he's a mentally gone or some
yeah but if he's mentally gone how does
he have a good memory but how can you
not remember my big beard yeah you know
even though there's a lot of brothers
with beers yeah but people everybody
remembers shark eula I don't know what
it is about it's like I think but I step
in a role people can feel my spirit I
don't know if I breathe louder or
because you walking over
you do it is that you do that every time
you go into a room no just like used to
though I used to be on sublight you know
how it is when you're younger you just
[ __ ] I'm Chewbacca yeah I look back
at some of the things that I've done and
it's like I see how much I'm matured
yeah and you know how it is like I'm
sure you watch old footage you're like
well you know I actually why I matured
more definitely and uh but you know a
lot of people they see it they love it
because you're still doing stuff that no
one everyone ever had the balls to do
everybody wants to see the wild charcoal
nobody wants to see the tame shark Gila
shark from Chicago originally yes sir
South Side South Side South Side south
side Pihl who started rapid win 87 1987
I wasn't that good until then I felt
until 91 but still I feel always trying
to revamp myself like how old are you 42
42 years old started rapping at 87
hip-hop started out in the park started
rapping it got good started hip-hop you
started out in the park started rapping
faster yeah I remember back in high
school when I was like going the shows
like and met at the metro and oh yeah
you'd always be outside what your tapes
wrapped in newspaper yeah I was like
MCed that's when I first met you Oh a
lot of just this is my ticket to
actually meet people yeah and now it's
wonderful I'm looking around like all
these people like celebrities like
yourself make it like making it people
that I've seen like mmm that were
confident enough to believe them they
believe in themselves and that's what
really makes a band then teamwork make
the dream work you know so that's like I
did it like people need I'll be honest I
get inspired by like yeah cuz I'm sure
you've seen a lot of people come up from
like the beginning to like you're not
because you know like everyone in the
city yeah I love to like it's like I
love to know success stories yeah it's
really keeps me going because I feel
like a carrot
because everyone knows me and they want
to know you no matter what you got the
worst day in your life right and
someone's like what's Lobby you know if
you just tell it what personal [ __ ]
obviously gonna get around every time I
run into you I've never seen you like in
a bad mood you always seem like you're
high-spirited I try to be because I
don't believe anyone deserves like any
negativity because I have a rough day
I'm supposed to go out to the bar and
bring that [ __ ] with me and yeah and
someone's like trying to celebrate
someone's trying to escape negativity
yeah yeah I think it's unfair to bring
negative energy to someone you know
that's good philosophy that's a great
philosophy
I disagree though Kamikaze don't feel
what I feel I let it build up sometimes
I talk to the bouncer he said well just
tell the people that push you up in
there yeah like I always say if I'm
gonna borrow my yo
don't call me macaroni dick I don't want
that nickname I was just playing around
and then they told her their friend it
doesn't know me that well and I was like
and I thought about was like I know I'm
gonna say sorry for for that and they're
gonna crack up like dough coffee bagger
Oh need a road I thought about it's kind
of like a dope name because rody but
then again you might think it's
microscopic penis he's a macaroni dick I
don't even like those type of names
because they're people you don't know
from different backgrounds they know you
they tell you about a joke and they're
telling you calling you that you want to
just be called you know sharp I want to
be called shark Allah and not these
weird aliases people give me but this is
that well I gave myself alligator booty
alligator boots I like that because
there's a lot of big old booties in the
city and I thought I was like alligator
it's just alligator booty if you ride
that booty
right you could possibly tail them well
yeah it's like a rodeo doe gonna roll
bar like wait what's a rodeo burger if
you get it at the crackhead menu at
Burger King and it gives you extreme gas
if you're lucky you'll get diarrhea but
okay you know about the rodeo burger
that's the one again the barbecue sauce
onion rings on it okay yeah good is this
tasty but for you for people like us
that's like we don't need it because
it'll it'll literally kill you yeah it's
it catches up it catches up but
sometimes it's just there right and it's
so fast so greasy I keep it to myself
it's like a it's like a secret you know
well never like yeah you know I just had
this burger king I just usually just try
to have it nobody was around when I did
it I don't tell them about it you know
yeah yeah just blow up they spot yeah
like you know you know bacon double
cheeseburger I get I get the worst [ __ ]
sometimes when the big double yeah well
no I'm saying the worst
I'll get the yeah the double bacon [ __ ]
not even be that great you know I got
upset I walked past some restaurant
I forget what Cydia it was recent and it
was a it was you could see in the
kitchen from the outside and they just
had this big thing of bacon or cook
bacon already just sitting ready to go
and uh it just kind of made me up
secondly I thought my bacon was made
with love and made right there made
fresh turns out theme of others get five
thousand strips of bacon ready to go
yeah cook cold s bake you know what
they probably they probably precooked
the bacon and then then then then the
flash fry it real quick to order cuz
that's how I used to do it at a brunch
spot I was that we would cook the bacon
in the oven and then whenever a fresh
order came out we throw it on the pan
real quick cuz it was ready it just no
just
and it is just like it's more of a time
efficiency thing so were you always very
outgoing always a people person I was
outgoing but I think I was shy and at
the same time to this day I think that
selling music in to people and
performing helps me break different
shyness climb very on shy but I'm very
shy and different levels sure
like I'm shy because you know it's kind
of sometimes if you be around people I
don't get no women then it's kind of
embarrassing you try and be shy because
you know they don't get no women so you
try and be I guess it's called humble
but uh I don't know it's weird I'm a
little bit different not like I got
dropped of my head as a kid but yeah you
know it's just I've always been like my
my guy like what kind of quiet but I'm
not bipolar when you were younger you
were and you were in a sports and yeah I
played baseball until I got hit in the
head with a baseball yeah wait so
there's a there's a there's a myth
there's a mythical story out there that
I've heard about you a bunch of time I
never talked to you about this I was
just trying to address this on the
podcast there's a story there's a
legendary story that said that one day
you had taken too much acid oh it kind
of wigged out and then you just haven't
been the same senses this is true story
someone tried to say that back in the
day and because I was so different
yeah because you are an eccentric fellow
so like I've heard that story before but
that sounds like the classical myth that
yeah I'm a little weird but I'm I mean I
never really like I've never had acid to
make me stay on ass okay my father's be
saying stuff in these streets I admire
what you do just because it's tough to
engage with people and try to crank cold
cell yeah music on the street cuz really
selling your personality right says you
selling yourself sort of people do you
remember your fur
sale on the street actually my first
sale was school I used to make tapes for
people and some people who like look
here's my lunch but I you here's here's
my leftover whatever like they didn't
touch it like people you know I yep
someone has fries they don't even eat
them they're hot
give him a tape my first sale though
actually literally sale is not like at
my ground around my grandma's house and
ninety holy [ __ ]
92 I needed transportation money to get
on the Dan Ryan so I was like I had
tapes those tapes would take me damn was
it 90 I don't consider trading tapes in
the hallway in high school for snicker
bars yeah a sale this is Margaret it's a
barter harder
I used to barter in high school like
that for stuff but my first initial sale
was definitely in the Southside and this
is when you were going to thingamajiggy
right yeah holy [ __ ] I wish I would have
remembered my first very sale I mean I
had to be honest man so do you ever done
any any selling your music on the street
uh I've done these I did it at my shows
like where I would be died one of yours
you're seeing it's haiku yeah I used to
rap back in the days for the listeners
and oh no I used to go by haiku
hey yo let's keep it a sweet I might be
a freak but I ain't no creep riding in
my Jeep short violence to the gallon
beat nails long like I'm trying to grow
jealous street drug have skeet balanced
by the way the Train and not remain in a
place of face my bunk another December
comes quicker every year and the liturgy
you thinking that it wasn't really there
old friendly unions good times little
kids
next get nubby when you go do some [ __ ]
over eat the fish fried spoiled on a
Sunday
I would do shows usually open up for
like a bigger act and then just run
around your an around the venue and
cells like that's regular yeah people on
the streets not in the city streets
about Liars but not that not the CDs not
on the nerves to do that you might have
to you already know uh shark I'm no I'm
no music manager or ANR anything like
that but in the changing times yo CDs
yeah are not the one man of choice
everyone's streaming everyone streaming
and downloading what are you doing to
adjust to the change in times I have to
keep up with the times but I don't like
the way that money looks at you
sometimes like the you know splinting
would like my producer so therefore I
gotta like so I saw framed arts too and
and like I saw stuff I try and have some
old vintage like a vinyl or mining so I
hustle hard snow tapes to I'm gonna get
back at it back in the tapes yeah tapes
are sewing again them yeah what about it
like like bulk just like a lot of stuff
I want to do yeah and I think they're
like when I went to that literally when
I was two days in the hospital it made
me think about how how much people how
much I love myself and how much I love
other people and how much I was at first
I was scared I like them sneakers I was
scared because thanks if I you welcome
if I can't get out there like I
compliment you and Jack last night if I
can't get out so nice jacket really
oh yeah yeah they don't break don't move
stand still I think this is what your
spider sounded like a reclusive
[Music]
me on pad is so fun she's gotta follow
follow me she said she said she said she
warned me but it was all cuz I'm me on
DS uh-huh did tell us all B's like a
down comforter all of them I fall yeah
yeah all relax and walk up in the spot
the undies on what's happening hi [ __ ]
is so smooth the undies got me go out
the [ __ ] [ __ ] my butt to the gym so
full Oh bumper to toe step back to the
line go for some good bits make me up
you know I danced it the Saints beat me
up is so far beyond these number one
he's got em all on they want to
they wanna go to another country hunter
rings they wanna get stop me
they want to get jumping Rumple Minze
they want to keep me company company
they think they wanna have fun with me
over me they wanna ride out his grace
not with me not with me the undies got a
smokin chuckle picked up of me beyond
these got I'm having fun
me hahahahahaha me and he's all up in
the street in the street the nvm
everyone up on this tree on his beak
and I see all up under make one to me
[Music]
[ __ ] I've been different this week I
think it's because of everywhere we've
been DS I think it's because I'm ever
wearing me undies [ __ ] when he's got
damn me on he's I feel good anyways
check out my undies dot-com / Hannibal
and get 20% off your first pair and a
satisfaction guarantee that you'll love
them or your money back
go to Mia nice calm / Hannibal 20% off
these are the best underwear I've ever
had I was wearing a pair - had all
pandas on them yesterday
[ __ ] was flies [ __ ] I feel great it's
almost like wearing nothing so you get
to feel like you wearing nothing without
having [ __ ] streaks on your jeans my
undies go to me undies calm / Hannibal
get 20% off
[Music]
you know I'm feeling conflicted about
something I'll tell you all about it I
you heard about the United Airlines
thing yeah what a drag the guy at the
doctor yeah the guy off the plane
because the flight was overbooked it was
really [ __ ] up but uh we'd go into LA
Thursday and United just had the best
prices by far and I had to book a flight
on there tough about that I understand
not about the paid 300 more a ticket
just because you know they had a little
miss Lam mishap that's probably not
gonna happen on this flight definitely
there's been worse this is the best time
to fly United you know her father's
gonna be super nice chair massages is
[ __ ] they messed up that's not cool
yeah no that's that that's good logic
that's the thing know where Airlines is
that is tough to I mean you can boycott
an airline you can but if you work how
we work is like okay you don't want to
fly Delta anymore then how you getting
the Tallahassee [ __ ] yeah oh you
wanna yeah you gotta do some real
mother's [ __ ] like you said before if
you boycotted everything that you
thought was wrong you wouldn't be able
to enjoy [ __ ] nothing's perfect about
anything you know man United they gonna
be super nice though the deals yeah yeah
yeah it worse could but in terrorists on
the damn train I mean aa plane it was
you know and they shouldn't have thrown
that man around like that then they
brought out his history and said he
exchanged drugs for sex like what the
[ __ ] I gotta do what I'm getting kicked
off the plane yeah yeah nothing to do
with that okay you shouldn't drag him
through the mud after you dragged him
out the plane - yeah but no I mean I
remember right after right after 9/11 I
went to LA for the first time this was
college cuz [ __ ] plane prices
oh yeah yeah set like so I flew out
there for like Halloween huh and
round-trip tickets were like $75 I'm
like yeah it's a tragedy that sucks but
nobody wanted to fly cuz everyone was
scared and I was like I'm sure
Security's gotten tighter everything's
gonna be alright that's a lot of wars
chickens yeah that's a lot of horse
checking not just warrants shoot my
hero's Qi Gong I want to sound like a
muscle [ __ ] we need some [ __ ]
because I'm Asian Korean Chinese chicken
- I love Korean barbecue it's great I
don't know here's I don't I like Korean
barbecue but I don't want to cook it at
my table yeah I don't want to do that
just make it I didn't come here I'm not
about to pay you so I can cook here
yeah cook at home that's why you gotta
come with me I do the cooking and you
want to place yeah I love I love Korean
barbecue just not because I'm Korean but
because it's French the biggest pressure
you cook it exactly how you want it's
right there you [ __ ] it and then I take
the roller grill all the time so it
feels like I'm going out with you and
then you start cooking away I got a
Korean person here I'm off then it gets
fun this new segment new segment new
segment segment all right so that's just
this segment is called declarative
statements
I'm gonna do 15 push-ups later okay all
right now I'm gonna put some ladies to
rest tuck them in make sure you're nice
and cleaned up I'm gonna make a beat
with the theremin and my new rubber
keyboard later later
right now declarative statements we were
we were doing our research but we're
legitimate journalists we'll check it we
take our job seriously
so we work just on this very TV screen
here we were watching your performance
on Chicago talk to us about that when
was that
well let's talk about the first one yes
the first yes that was a 2006 or 2006 I
gotta give my dates better now that I
come together uh Jake Austin this guy I
met through JB chill you know JB chill
from WH okay he referred me to him and
he was a fan he bought my wax because I
once you get on a show there's no curse
words and you could do two songs a bunch
of children and background parents or
their girls right well right floor
artists that's the nation of this job
yeah I was like this is a chance for me
to get broadcasted and and talk to the
kids and talk to the kids a good look
for me too yeah I'm saying hey I could
be a Manny one day but uh it was a good
it was I was extra excited cuz Jake's
son and daughter weren't in there I was
like I always wanted to be a mentor kids
before like you're older so I get to the
point I really wanted to do I was
honored to do it and it turned out to be
a success the first time and they're so
good the energy was great it was a song
I had watched it today and it was just
it was fascinating to see somebody just
freestyling on a late-night TV
performance just somebody just
obviously freestyling and having fun and
the kids are behind go go is a kids show
right this is a public access public
access as kids in the background but the
kids with their hands are it's a great
visual yeah
and use this freestyling off the time yo
I want you to put your hands in the air
put them all up baby put them in the air
do what you gotta do if you can with the
kids there's been some legit artist has
done that too like one of them I paid
the way for the rapper's to do it cuz
big me it's not like I got a remix out
of them but it was like well they saw me
up this way well this guy shark do it
comfortable with TV yeah okay so the
second before was you planted out a
little bit then happens all you have to
do in the shark hands before you went
out there and then walked out on the
guys back piggyback right
Sugar's big booty costume
go ahead and bring that back a couple of
time rewind I'm a big fan of good
entrances and now is a good engine Thank
You meryt for the listeners at home you
got it you got a google shark EULA
Chicago go go go and watch both wealth
appearance we'll put them in and doesn't
want a third one and that was like I got
oh you had a third appearance yeah [ __ ]
but it's kind of funny man is like at
this verse I was like I keep the holes
running like a holes and I'm the fireman
holes I don't know I was like putting
metaphors together that language just
come out of nowhere it's like you know
how you say a spirit of a hotel room of
dirty sex yeah well in this building it
was the spirit of kids and parents and
people wanted to stop the violence in
the community and it was tripped out
there was like it was like most of you
like his but there was a few black kids
and then there are few Latino kids if
you know why kids that look like they
were white they were Latino but I didn't
care about their Chinese I just felt
like this is great because it's a kiss
like me they're gonna get only older
that yeah you know and so they can carry
me on a thing that really is I'm working
on you know how you're out in public
some of the young people that have sons
and daughters in there looking at you or
like what is this person looking at
sometimes you gotta like before you go
to see like oh that person probably see
me somewhere yeah so it's like sometimes
you push those people away but what
celebrity do you know this so accessible
where you can just they're just like on
10 all the time I'm China it's a couple
people that met on 10 but are very
gracious and oh yeah you're one of them
no no absolutely not I have my I try my
best to be but I definitely have my
moments where I lapse it's a being
the person for a moment people can be
annoying though
it can be but you gotta I'm working on
it cuz it's not it's like you said
nobody usually deserves negativity I try
to be nice and it made me crack a joke
yeah and give them the signature laugh
[Laughter]
with somebody's eye look I was looking
at Twitter earlier tomorrow I met
Hannibal a big kitchen and he did his
laughs and everything yesterday was
hilarious cuz we went to the Bulls game
yeah this guy came out of the bathroom
like straight up out the bathroom hand
open to shake mean I was as I pound too
much it's too much right out the bathtub
oh it should be thirsty thirsty watching
your hands even if you washed your hands
is just this is a bathroom yeah just you
just had your dick in your hands you
were in front of the bathroom yeah he
might have to clean his hands and I
might look somebody's hand they might
have been disgusted just because they
weren't mad about it yeah starstruck it
was a conference the context of it was
no context right straight out of the
bathroom he was body buddy
yeah metaphor leaf clover it's over you
always have like yeah go ahead sorry I
like to combine words yeah four leaf
clover it's overlooking sporty like a
Casanova jumped into the 66 Nova like
you want wish you had a Range Rover but
still you got some leotards and some
penny loafers penny loafers with a loaf
of bread a shredder get the cheese
melted over your burger and eat that
damn [ __ ] like he bought the murderer
get in the toilet like you bought to
wipe your booty then look at the facts
of life like Tootsie
this gear got a big booty as big as
3,000 ferrets I don't know if you want
to hear it you know the titles are
always great did Martin Luther King jr.
whopper and cheese Yeah right always the
other mother tango and candle for cash
Black team angular bag heat Blackie man
EULA
that I wish it was so I mean it sells
but I wish I got more
I need that on vinyl but I'm proud of
that last why I did that in Louisiana
and and I look at the character I've
made on it because like so much it is
like wow this hell didn't have some
smooth though under the shark you know
yeah you're helping me I'm helping you
were teamwork make the dream work
that's what I'm about Network get work
you work how long you been obscene he's
been babbling for a mement dabble in for
a minute it's for fun and I've been I
think I like the idea of putting out an
album I actually like putting out an
album we're getting close we and just
the Squarespace ad ideas and so it's
just a fun this this allows it's just
it's fun to just freestyling and goof
off it's a good it's a good good way to
vent and just you know have fun right
there if you get you and get you right
now to participate yeah yeah you I give
it you are you are there I'm in running
through a little drums what do we think
this is do some drums actually put the
famine on let's do some drums and let's
see how it goes all right
[Music]
yo chillin with Hannibal how much do we
like em we'll win cannibals
yo we toxic we not toxic to one another
chillin with my Korean and my brother my
brown brother
my queen she's from Europe I got some
syrup on the pancakes
i watch Ricky Ricky Lake Ricky Schroder
yo Ricky Schroder the bridge is over
there you got the metaphor leaf clover
oh I've been the boulder the altitude
had me coughing up all my homies
shoulder I got asthma
Oh Matt a rapper I played a video game
with parappa how do you talk a Davos in
my bladder Oh school I go bladder no
bladder go finger chicken fingers
chicken wings we doing that thing
Halloween $75 round trip to LA kali
greens parlay kick it like the
old-school rap like Pele hey she's kind
of hairy but she shaves
come on the cemetery yeah I bought a
shirt from the money I made selling
bootleg Blue Byte beats by dre
headphones that bar was too long and I
mess it up
it saw me on the drums confess it up he
said that they had a gun on a table old
lion don't even try it
Paige beat Sony stressed ocular in the
potty poo and sparked on stuff Oh
shockula Bardot stuff my party tonight
shitty yeah it's like you're a tool that
we're that lucky
you know it's bumpin you know it's a big
boo-boo
you still [ __ ] with board games yeah a
little bit not Ouija but we like Luigi
trouble and I like I like a Ouija board
trouble and a hungry hungry
wait but what about we was about you
know like the witches that's why you eat
a lot of garlic you eat garlic to defend
wait that's vampires exactly when I'm in
the streets of Chicago I feel like
there's vampires so you think there's
real actual vampires out there oh yeah
we should have opened a podcast with
this what okay there are hella garlic me
like energy vampires like bad people are
you is like an actual like so those
people are white like there are some
people out there that they're like
especially uh if you're a celebrity you
know person you start seeing look around
their energy takers but they're also
people that actually suck blood in the
world just like theirs and that [ __ ]
dogs and ass there's what I'm gonna get
fun by dogs and ass huh I'm not saying I
know those people and I don't want to
know those people you know them they
just haven't told you that they do that
right you've met a lot of people man and
chances are you've met somebody
[Laughter]
yeah vampires uh well you know spiders
are a lot like vampires they get fangs
burn then they get it you know what I'm
saying they drink they I think they
drink blood right
yeah that's why my [ __ ] swollen like a
piece of lung he's already gave the
spider Mike damn spider-man Jesus [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] with you now man he followed
you here that's insane hopped in your
backpack have you had me cuz you always
you out and about you meeting all times
have you had some situations just gettin
hairy in the streets are you good with
your hands
oh no some martial arts you see this for
you Oh what the [ __ ] I had to knock a
couple guys out because one guy just
slammed my CDs down and he flex
danbury's I don't want that [ __ ] and
also it's like the police were cross
street it was what I enjoy was jumping
they just then enjoy in Wicker Park yeah
you see you around they're like yeah and
then yeah I think then you never didn't
do nothing and they saw that I
[ __ ] with in there just like it was this
like before after like the whole chacha
fication I'll call it of that Street
because before it was just those two
spots and it was kind of like dead and
then Isla nowhere out of nowhere just
five thousand and seven or eight okay so
it was kind of slow demise of it going
into this other world yeah you walk down
the street with ice cream it's okay to
put your nose up in front of someone you
knew last year Oh what are you up to
well I'm doing this hey wait a minute
I just want you to come to my show have
a good time drink some beers cuz I
remember seeing you walking up and down
that Street when it wasn't like that so
it's like you already own that Street
before them [ __ ] I used to go
yeah house Oh bow-bow
yeah well you know it used to be before
the notary used to be the hot house oh
you know you fight over no I don't
remember passed the note no I don't
check this out though well you're a
younger it was an play say your uncle
with you could go in with like a family
member they had like jazz stuff yeah and
it was I guess owners on the same thing
over there but it was like it was weird
we had to jog to the car back in 1990
we'd be in there sweating to get to this
hip-hop party a Westside cast name I
forget the name of them but Chris with
conflict Oh suggests they were kind of
like they wore a lot of Polish [ __ ] we
go and there you have it
Twilight tone would be DJing and there
you go here's a promotion this is how
you know I'm not a hater it's like I
said someone's name that most people
some people are afraid to say names but
it was it was kind of like they play 90s
hip-hop kind of like bar vertigo where I
you see you a Antonio yeah that's right
five vertigo which is another blind
Robin right yeah yeah yeah they changed
the tip line yeah it was hello yes it
was like I remember I never forget that
you bought a tape back then and you went
to college you're like all the people go
to college like DJ Murray and these
people go to college at Carbondale I was
like oh this is cool yeah this is a
different
breed of people yeah vertigo was like
the carbondale Spock is me getting Maria
Hannibal we'd all like critical ya rod
number rod right yeah yeah that spot
down that's got the black beetle that
was like our join us yeah yeah dude that
was that's right you were around a lot
for that I will come around uh because
was it was flying well here's a question
out of all the errors like of hip hop in
Chicago if you've been through the whole
gamut since the beginning I feel like
since the beginning to now what era and
what area like what seem was your
favorite like when was it like the best
you thinking like where was it centered
around me I thought it was like 89 to
like 90 like 799 who was popping that
was that like rubber room yeah rubber
room was popping in the 90s yeah my west
side yeah Bellwood yeah would a rubber
rubber room sorry no no you know they're
dope man to some way like they were like
oh that's a group yeah there's a venue
you know ballpark hardcore like hardcore
like rap group they sounded kind of like
company flow okay yeah yeah let's place
in some rubber room right here in post
three lot the damn work
Oh
they were slept on man they were a
pinnacle Chicago group he taught my
Marimo lumber Oh all natural Oh all
natural the moment yeah that's when they
that was there that's that time you're
tired number years it was fun because
you can go to the Abbey pub that was
that wasn't the to thousands old Abbey
pub wasn't popular also mm they're
popping in the 90s well you know was
popping for me lad that I liked a lot
was no I like the simplicity of meeting
people and they were called my land my
mom's land phone to be like it's thick
there she'd be like she'd be mad at me
no you don't live you know live here
don't ever call here no more yeah and I
remember one time I'm with the Howards
home coming back in 93 and I met mos def
from bush babies and I gave him my home
number he said I'll call you I kid you
not I knew it was him not cuz because
like I'm a friendly guy you know it's
like I could even ask you how am I gonna
get a record deal and I'm like only like
19 but he calls like a job how you doing
in New York accent I guess they're like
you got in your head accent yeah yeah I
was like that's the last thing my mother
wanted me to be was a rapper mmm because
she was like she didn't believe it and I
was like I'm the type of guy clear like
I have no books four days of just
instead of being pampered and being
doing something stupid I was right yeah
all right I will constantly write I'll
write to this day I still do it instead
of being negative right and it's like
that's what I want to do is just write
it with what I'm talking to you like
what I'm doing even a freestyle yeah I
think it's not so great but I'm thinking
about it if my freestyle is not always
that great just make it authentic
not overly Ave strength mm-hmm kind of
like keep it simple and that's why I
liked about our freestyle together
because it was like natural yeah it kind
of something to live for you know let's
backtrack a little bit you said you saw
most death oh yeah and I was in a bush
babies he was a book called bush break
yeah yeah well he wasn't in Bush babies
he was just featured all right yeah yeah
that was a good track anyway yeah it was
like I was like I would get him and meet
a lot of people but my mother when he
was trying to put you on or something I
think you wanted to like cuz I would
travel out to the east coast allows the
type of guy where I go without a sky
pager I go out there pure trust of
wanting to learn mmm Tuesday I'm eager
to learn yeah yeah let's talk about
those trips though those East Coast
trips no goofy how homecoming made some
trips out to New York in the 90s it was
fun because I would see people on 125th
Street in Harlem selling mixtapes in 93
92 no first time was 93 yeah I got hurt
a UPS hurt my leg I fell between a
trailer and what happened was when I hit
New York I wasn't in no pain because I
was seeing a physical therapist I was
like I went out there with about 25 dug
dug caves my little check I had from ups
and to be honest with you is the best
thing that ever had on me man was to go
out there and see people I've seen on
video I saw dreads and his BMW things
like that you see a rat how long's you
spent out there I was there for a week
and a half to two weeks my friend had a
management with Mobb Deep's management
he was you know dancer so he got us all
me and my homie that went and this guy
named Nino we got auditions with him he
could pull he imposes our manager I
might I say his name but he was a dancer
we're all two dancers but we dance
better than the dude and the one thing I
didn't like about it was he got the part
and we and I had we had I had access to
his Jeep so I'm driving around and
see I didn't grow up in we slept in that
Jeep we got lost in the jersey
turnpiking edgy we listen to music in
the Jeep but I never forget playing mad
lion and and then seeing him out there
in the street seeing Karras one Scene da
scene you name it and somebody from New
Year's iru
you know when I went to the tunnel ya
feel like the way I did like you're from
Brownsville Brooklyn I was like no I'm
from Chicago said stop lying
well the tunnel was this is legendary
hip-hop night you know New York start
with Funk Flex right yeah you've been
there you said no had been there I used
to live but the tunnel was done by the
time I lived in New York how was that
tunnel man I've heard everyone seen the
documentaries about it and heard the
stories when I was a crazy energy it was
a keep in mind I knew to be quiet
because when I'm out of town
I just wanted my dancing to speak for it
so but people were nice to me like I
never forget smoking a blunt what a do
this and you a dancer like break dance
or a dancer like Usher not like Usher
more like break break dance in the night
if I get out do two robot go yeah break
in but keep in mind I'm you know I'm
from Chicago hip I was created in New
York so there's a lot of competition
right so I think that really helped me
out by seeing you are good I mean mean
people from where it got started and uh
so I would battle people I didn't even
know from the Bronx or whatever but the
same time I wasn't like no hard feelin's
like oh man you didn't move don't move
don't move don't move don't move but the
fashion always hit in New York before I
hit Chicago but so I loved it because I
can like check out new stuff and it gave
me ideas how to put my clothes together
yeah you know even though I had my own
style but you get out there you kind of
like Pete Rock is big and you know uh
you know the you know you it's like you
just really appreciate the whole factor
they created hip hop to stop gangbang
right and I was like this is the lineage
is different than it is here we have
lineage for gangbang and a lot of people
we never knock a gangbanger but at the
same time I wish some of the gangbangers
would be rappers they do use to bebas
nice play I did not never gangbang yeah
not even know I buy weave you be a good
asset to the Vice Lords positive energy
teach them there's a lot of things know
what don't shoot that guy yeah social
social skills yeah
teach them a networking right how do you
know how to like sell the product also
make the customer leave happy oh yeah
you know I feel like you'd be a great I
feel like drugs yeah look I know you had
a bad day but put that gun away let me
show you how to sell this crack that
that's good that's a good gangbanger
friend right there yeah yeah let's go to
jail together getting my whip
make sure you have like a pound of coke
in there let's all go down man yeah
here's how many songs do you think
you've recorded oh my god probably like
the be honest with you 365 days in a
year
some nights on those tapes I do like 12
yeah so I think I got like about 5,000
like floating around you know we gotta
have done here's an idea
we should have your you Circle it yo we
should out your entire library analog
digitize and just upload it and upload
it get rich get rich get rich which I
think we should just sort of people can
just have access yeah so the whole thing
you gotta you gotta make it simple for
people yeah and now we'll make it simple
or at least let's start with your your
your favorite ten song yeah put it away
you put it away something man we'll work
out something because what do say when
people put it on wax you know they get
seventy percent you get thirty yeah
still they're coming out of a pocket to
manufacture that [ __ ]
oh that's it 70/30 is a terrible deal
even if they're putting it together
whoever [ __ ] whoever said that what do
you think the best the best I mean the
best deity well the best deal is you
know you all initiated seven that's the
best deal but yeah yeah usually a good
fair label does like a 50/50 after after
they recoup the Gloucester's [ __ ] that's
how I've always seen it yeah that's how
I see you know I'm no goddamn I'm no
Berry Gordy what do I know I'm no I'm no
Scott Storch what the hell am I talking
about I'm no Jermaine Dupree I don't
know [ __ ] Jermaine Dupri still around
hey waited me you do not be as nice yeah
Jermaine Dupri is yeah he DJ was he DJ
some [ __ ] I was in Phoenix or somewhere
San Diego
yeah Jermaine Dupri was a comic-con
party I remember I was that means he's
not I think he was deleted and it wasn't
anything that jarring happened you know
what I mean like I was like if it's not
a memorable performance it probably
wasn't a good one because if it was good
you probably would have stopped and been
like what's going on over there cuz I
know you you're a type of person that
likes to really take in the energy or a
room and if somebody was killing it you
would have stopped for a second a bit
like this DJ is killing it I I kind of
it was it was a different type of event
what was commercial well yeah it was I
think it was some type of rooftop party
some also I might be lying okay
you know I might
make another s4 that's the thing that's
in is it's making up stuff so yeah we go
get some more circular music online and
all of that and let's close it out man
yeah thank thank you for coming on to
the show all right I hope you got your
messages across yes yes it was my
website yeah Charlotte calm Charlotte
info I don't have my whole catalogue
online but you can get way you know what
stuff is on that's on youtube but I want
more out there not just you know you see
like four albums on Spotfire iTunes I
want my whole life journey like you're
right I want to put everything out yeah
because it gives more people to choose
from instead of you know you go look at
a menu you want to get anything what you
want how you want it yeah Burger King
well like a buffet Mike bit over so I
can take over your booty
okay thanks Matt give us a quick sing in
tune go go just go at it
Jerry curls are juicy girls older juicy
pear Oh Jerry
[Music]
bring your dishes out beat your and
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah Oh God they're better juicy booty
all right that's good that's it
[Music]
[Music]